an officer-involved shooting leaves one
person dead happen on the east side of
the valley thank you for joining us at
five I'm Brian Loftus and I'm Sasha
Loftus this happened this morning near
Charleston and lamb that's where we find
Joshua peguero he joins us live with the
latest from Metro Police Joshua
it's still very much of an active scene
here about 15 minutes ago police
actually let us get closer and I'm gonna
step out of the way so my photographer
can zoom in it's hard to see because the
sun isn't out anymore but there's a
vehicle that police have blocked off
they're so crime scene tape as well on
Calusa Circle Metro Police say they
started with the roadways incident at
around 11 this morning at Nellis and
Bonanza a person pulled out a gun at
another driver police found that person
who was said to have the gun tries to
pull them tries to pull them over but
the driver took off police initiated a
vehicle Pursuit ending in a neighborhood
near Colusa Circle in Sacramento Drive
officers then fired into the vehicle
killing the driver but didn't say
whether that person Grand police or
showed a weapon a witness I spoke to
when we first arrived that news had
police shot a woman
my mom said she saw them shoot the lady
in the red car like the shots were at
her
now just to be clear police have not
said whether the person that they shot
was a man or a woman
um as you can see it's still very much
of an active scene no one else was hurt
in the shooting and we don't know when
their investigation will end reporting
live near Charleston and lamb Joshua
peguero eight news now